Thanksgiving it's two minutes after the
hour of nine o'clock and this book on
the desk published by Cambridge is
titled on Capitol Hill the struggle to
reform Congress and its consequences
1948 to 2000 last week we talked to the
Senate historian dick Baker and on your
screen is Julian Zelizer in Boston good
morning hi thanks for having me what's
this book about to start with it's a
book about how liberal politicians and
liberal reformers during the 1950s and
60s tried to reform both the House and
Senate to make it more open to make it
more receptive to liberal legislation
and how they changed Congress during the
1970s opening up putting it on
television creating ethics laws and the
second part is about how conservatives
ended up being much better at working in
the new legislative system and how they
used a lot of the reforms the Liberals
had created in the 50s 60s and 70s to
really succeed in an institution that
had been dominated by Democrats how did
you go about studying this archives I'm
a historian by training and after doing
a lot of reading on on Congress during
this period I traveled to different
parts of the country to look at
congressional papers of members who had
served and that committee papers in
Washington DC and at the papers of many
organizations who had been involved in
these reform efforts ranging from the
n-double-a-cp to the Americans for
democratic action so it's a lot of
traveling a lot of archival research i
did some interviewing but the archival
research was the heart of my heart of my
work you say the conservatives that took
advantage of the changes in the in the
70s that the liberals had started give
us an example how'd they do it one of
the examples is ethics rules one of the
big areas where reformers in the 70s
wanted to improve on the institution was
to create concrete ethics rules and
regulations that legislators had to
follow so you couldn't you know earn so
much income outside of your work in
Congress there were limits on
you could take contributions from on
what kind of money you could receive one
of the people who realize that those
ethics laws could be used to bring down
powerful politicians was a young
legislator from Georgia named newt
gingrich and one of his first acts in
1979 was to go after representative
Charlie digs on ethics violations
another area is the televising of
Congress the Young Republicans who come
of age in the late 70s realized that the
televised and open congress could offer
them an opportunity to speak directly to
their constituents and and they use this
this channel itself c-span to their own
to their own advantage to go after
Speaker of the House Tip O'Neill in 1984
have the Democrats used this channel for
instance since 1995 when the republicans
took over the same way the Republicans
did I don't think as effectively
obviously both parties realize that all
the reforms of the 1970s offered tools
in in standard you know party party
warfare but I think overall you know
since the 1980s and even since 95
Democrats have not been quite as good
not only on this channel but on the
other cable media that have emerged from
you know the Fox News MSNBC news they
just haven't been quite as good at using
it to their ends how would it be
different if you were a member of
Congress in the 70s and say you were in
there today what kind of things that you
could or could not do that was changed
well let's take let me take the 60s
before the reforms actually happened so
if you were serving during that period
and the most likely person to have a lot
of power during that year it was a
committee chair in the house it was an
era since the 1920s when Committee
Chairman had a lot of autonomy from the
leaders of the parties to do whatever
they wanted so someone like a Howard
Smith who was the chairman of the Rules
Committee after 1955 he was a southern
conservative from Virginia had a lot of
autonomy as the chair to push the bills
that he wanted her to prevent the bills
that
he didn't want from coming to the floor
Howard Smith didn't really listen off
into the leadership of the Democratic
Party during the 1960's there was also a
lot less media and public scrutiny the
things you did were not on television
there was not a c-span the media itself
couldn't get into things often like the
hearings on different bills so it was
much more insular a lot of the work went
on behind closed doors and third went
going back to the ethics rules there
were that you know the ethics committees
are only set up in the 1960s in the
house and the Senate and it's not until
nineteen seventy-seven in 1978 that the
House and Senate adopt really concrete
ethics regulations on issues such as
financial disclosure or outside income
so you had a lot more leeway in the
older committee era tu to mobile ought
to do what you wanted on a lot of these
financial issues earlier in the program
we talked about a Janet hook story in
the los angeles times that we found this
morning in the philadelphia inquirer and
at the end on his GOP wheels its slim
majority like a mandate and there in the
center is a picture of Tom DeLay he said
it we want a rule change allowing him to
keep the leadership post even if he is
indicted what about the subject of a
comm delay the the whole business of the
Ethics Committee and what they found
against him and then the slap on the
wrist of the member who brought the
charges in the first place can you put
that all into context yeah part of what
you're seeing now is that the Republican
leadership is in some ways going back on
reforms that they had supported back in
the 70s and 80s as a way as a way to
obtain power so what happened with Tom
DeLay is the Ethics Committee did find
you know many questionable activities
from from events that he had held where
people who interest groups you know like
golf events where interest groups had
attended to raise money and to get power
to two other sorts of irregularities and
and and one of the issues is and i think
it was nineteen ninety-three the house
republicans had accepted a rule whereby
if a leader is indicted they had to step
down and the reason they did that was
they wanted to go after the leadership
of the Democratic leadership at that
time again it was part of the period
where they realize these ethics rules
could be used against the Democrats
quite effectively but now Tom DeLay is
the leader and the Republicans are in
command and some of these rules are
troublesome for them so I think what you
saw with the Republicans supporting tom
delay in saying that even if he is
indicted he can still serve is a
reversal of some of the policies that
looked good when they were in a minority
the Republicans but don't look quite so
good now that they are in power our
guest got highest honors in history at
Brandeis back in 1991 he got a master's
in in the department of history at Johns
Hopkins in 1993 and as a PhD in the
department of history at Johns Hopkins
from 1996 you are at the Brookings
Institution as a research fellow back in
the early or the middle 90s since then
you've taught I understand if I my list
is correct at the state university of
new york at albany and now you're both
at boston university and an associate
over at harvard now i'm a professor of
history at boston university and yeah
I'm a faculty associate it's called at a
center for american political studies
that they have in harvard but my my post
is at boston university right now what
do you find when you talk just to
average americans who don't study the
congress that they really have no idea i
mean what do you find that they have
known the idea about so bad would ask a
question when it comes to congress and
how to understand it i hate to say it
but almost everything the history of
Congress or how Congress works today
generally remains a mystery for many
Americans when I talk to students who
are just entering or I talked to friends
who are not in academia they can always
tell me a good amount about the
president's for example in the 20th
century well they could tell me a bit
about the Supreme Court but when you ask
about a some of the history of Congress
or be some of the ways in which Congress
works today for example this whole
debate over ethics and Tom DeLay they
know
almost nothing about it it's an issue
that people are not exposed to and it's
very troublesome given the role that
Congress plays in in this in this
country we're going to put the numbers
up on the screen in a moment but I want
to just go through some well you can see
them there you can begin dining now if
you want to join us with our guest who
is in Boston this morning Julian Zelizer
who is the author of on Capitol Hill
will show you the book in a moment when
I go through some of the statistics that
we have from the current Congress the
current is 229 well actually the
currents 249 and 205 Democrats but the
new one in the 109th will be 2 30 12 to
0 1 and 1 independent however there's
two seats in Louisiana that haven't been
decided and so it could go up a couple
more for either side the current Senate
is 51-48 one and the new one will be
5544 one the one being jim jeffords of
vermont the 109th conference at congress
the average age in the senate 60.3 five
years in the house 55 point oh eight
years and the 109th House members under
the age of 40 25 let me stop at the age
business right there is there anything
unusual about these ages now Congress
that's one of the constants throughout
the 20th century except for certain
moments it tends to be legislators from
the 50 and up age group so it's still a
pretty low number that are in the
younger ages and i think the age
actually reflects the politics you see a
lot of the issues that we are dealing
with our issues that are of concern to
that 50 plus generation such as Social
Security and Medicare a lot of the ways
in which debates are handled in Congress
reflects those 50 and 60 year old
experience we we still see Iraq through
the prism of Vietnam and part of that
reflects the age of the legislators I
think that's a very telling statistic
that you showed and so that it's not
unusual and there have been moments when
Congress becomes younger in the mid
seventies when these reforms takes place
that's actually one of the things that
happens in the nineteen seventy-four
Watergate baby election you have an
influx of younger men
and that often leads to a shake-up of
the system let me make a statement just
for the purposes of letting him bounce
off of it the Republicans since they've
taken over in Congress are no different
when it comes to reform and changed and
the Democrats were when they control it
for 40 years there's a lot of validity
to that the Republicans since 1994 there
when they start they do try to pass a
few reforms and they succeed that
further empower the party in the house
the party leadership they put term
limits on committee chairman they put
term limits on the speaker but since 94
and the historic election of that
Republican class there has not been a
lot of appetite among Republicans for
any further reform and in addition that
Republicans have really been using the
tools of the majority in the same way
the Democrats in the 1970s and 80s did
if not a little a little more forcefully
they have really been blocking out
Democratic participation and doing a lot
of the things that Republicans in the
80s and complained about in the house
about about about the Democrats many
people are making the same complaints
within the Democratic Party about Denny
Hastert that people like Newt Gingrich
made about about Tip O'Neill in the
1980s here's the book on Capitol Hill
the struggle to reform Congress and its
consequences 1948 to 2000 Julian Zelizer
professor at Boston University Redford
Michigan you're on the air go ahead
please yes I have a question that you
had said briefly about the Supreme Court
people seem to know about which I don't
agree with you now if we take over
Supreme Court all the Republicans we
have a clean sweep with the House and
Senate and they mandate will we have it
all did you understand that mr. Sullivan
I didn't hear the second part of the
question the first basically she wants
to know and I think that most people
would think that the Republic I think
there's seven and out of nine
Republicans yeah on the Supreme Court
and she suggested that if the
Republicans take over the Supreme Court
and they'd have it all basically do they
have it all now uh look if they can
expand them
geordie on the Supreme Court it would
obviously improve their chances to
solidify issues such such as abortion
rights or other issues that that will
emerge in the next few years they
already have it all I mean they have a
very strong command in the White House
and Congress and still have the majority
in the Supreme Court obviously expanding
that in the next few years would be very
important eliminating some of the
moderates is something that the Bush
administration and Republicans in
Congress are looking for in terms of the
first part of the question she is right
i mean we still don't know a lot about
the supreme court but i think someone
like Chief Justice Earl Warren and what
he did in the 1960s you'll find more in
the history books then congressman
Wilbur Mills who I wrote my first book
about the chairman of the House Ways and
Means Committee so I think there is
still more known history about the
Supreme Court then there is about
Congress everyone has suggested in these
news articles that to watch this room
court on Monday when the Supreme Court
sits and whether or not Chief Justice
Rehnquist happens to be back in the
chair let's go to Philadelphia you're on
the air yes I just want it I say the
biggest problem we have in the country
really is the American vote at the
unintelligent and American voter i think
ninety-five percent of the voters really
don't know what's going on they vote
with their Bible they vote with this but
in the last election now how can they
possibly possibly vote for that man for
sure with all the war going on a sink
hole over there and with the income tax
situation want to make it permanent once
they get that permanent they'll never
ever change back let me want to try to
keep the subject on what's going on in
the house of representatives and you
study much in the Senate professor yes
yes I have and in this book i also have
about the filibuster issue and how
parties became stronger in the Senate as
well as the house during the seventies
so yes I have now going back to the
house for the moment and we use this
earlier quote from Tom DeLay he says my
fellow conservatives we have waited our
entire lives for the chance the American
people have given us in the next two
years I pledge to each and every one of
you we will seize it what kind of power
do they have to seize this if they want
to
they have to be careful but they have
the same power actually in the house
that they had a few months ago it hasn't
changed that dramatically the
Republicans have the power to control
the schedule of what will be voted on on
the floor of the house the Republicans
as the majority have the power to put
certain rules and regulations on a bill
when they're being debated so that it is
favorable to passage they are also able
to exclude Democrats and more
questionable tactics from from
participating in conference committees
for example or or even House committees
and they are also able to have a yet
another round a fundraising advantage
because money is likely to flow toward
Republican coffers now an even greater
volume because it looks like they have
this majority on the other hand delay
and Republicans have to be aware that in
many ways their mandate is not much
greater than it was a few years ago it's
still a it's still a slim majority that
they have and if delay looks at the
history of his own party in recent years
Republicans often overplay their hand
they did that in 94 with Bill Clinton
they have these very fierce budget
battles where Clinton is able to best
them even though it looked like just as
it does today that this country had
given a mandate to the congressional
Republicans to do what they wanted so on
the one hand they do have these powers
of the majority in the house that that
help them push through what they want
but it on the other hand it's not that
it's not that much different and and
that's where Republicans really have to
be careful in the next couple of years
ten or Lake Texas you're on the air oh
thank you Brian for taking my call it's
been a long time watching I'm called a
couple of times I go back to watching
you when you used to come on down here
just about three hours a day and then we
had to keep fighting to get y'all to go
on now we got you three some three towns
it's really great anyway what I wanted
to say was about this talking about the
rules in the house and you're talking
about the not having to leave your seat
until you're indicted and not thinking
about that so much is it is what I think
about is is an indictment still not a
conviction
and down here in our part of the country
you can get indicted for a lot of things
that get thrown out before you ever get
to ever get to trial and I know kay
bailey hutchison was indicted by this
same attorney general and it was thrown
out before it ever got to ever got to
any trial in this is this he wasn't
Attorney General I'm sorry is a district
attorney over in Austin which is a very
liberal part of our of our state and he
talks about about having indicted a lot
of Democrats but at one time that's all
he had the indict over there because we
working we were everybody was a Democrat
down here but all the Democrats he ever
indicted were really conservative
Democrats you're probably Republicans
today so what he's got to say I would
really take with a grain of salt I
certainly wouldn't want to for a person
have to quit his job just because he was
indicted I at least like to work wait
until he had a trial alright so thanks
but let me add to this professor you
know when when they the caucus voted by
voice vote to support Tom DeLay and they
wouldn't have to leave this job a lot of
people wrote that the Democrats don't
even have a rule like this so explain to
a couple things one what kind of powers
the caucus have to why did they resend
this and three how can the Democrats
criticize delay when they don't even
have a rule like this the first is that
reforms can take place in two ways one
is Congress can actually pass a statute
to change the way Congress is organized
or the rules that govern all legislators
the other is reformed could take place
just threw a party caucus so in the past
both Democrats and Republicans have
instituted certain changes that only
apply to the members of their party
certain rules which are very common to
take place through the Congress through
the caucus are the rules about
leadership you know what why you can be
a chairman or why you could be a
majority leader why
you can be speaker is often an issue
handled through the party not not
through Congress as a whole or the house
as a whole that's what happened with
with the indictments that's the first
part the second part is I think the
caller actually raised a really good
point about in the era we're in where
scandal politics has become quite
pervasive in the last two decades or so
there is an argument to be made that we
have to be a bit more cautious about
kicking leaders out or removing them
from a position just when they are
indicted because you know as these
charges escalate it's dangerous to throw
people out before they're actually
convicted I don't think that's the
argument the Republicans were making in
their caucus I think and it's again it
was behind closed doors and I think it
was an unrecorded vote if I'm correct so
it's hard to know exactly what's going
on but I would speculate this was really
about protecting a leader who has become
quite important to the party and I think
a more cynical rationale is what took
place rather than a very good point that
could be debated that the that the
caller made finally the reason I think
some Democrats who don't have that rule
in their own party can still criticize
the Republicans as this was a Republican
rule made and use to criticize
Democratic leaders so just because the
Democrats have have not adopted it the
fact that Republicans are ascending on a
rule while they're in the leadership and
when it can affect them can still be
seen as problematic that you shouldn't
change the rules even for your own party
at you know just because your own
position has changed our guest Julian
Zelizer is a professor to Boston
University and he teaches the 20th
century US history let's go to buffalo
new york you're on the air um yes I
wanted to go back to something that you
were talking about a little bit earlier
although i'm calling from Buffalo I work
in Washington DC for a non-profit
grassroots organization called results
and just by way of background for my
question we have a very educated
grassroots that understand that the real
power is in Congress for issues except
for perhaps the final decision on when
to go to war and in the aftermath of the
election I'm calling it on the Democrats
line even though we're nonpartisan
a lot of my friends and people that I
work with we're very upset that Carrie
didn't win and thought that that had
these amazing implications for policy
and while it may on the one hand how do
we get across to your average citizen
and and spread the message through our
grassroots that as far as losing seats
in Congress goes that is actually going
to have in many ways a much more detrol
impact a detrimental impact on some of
our issues you know we people don't
realize that they have access to these
members in their home districts they can
go to their office they can talk to
their staff having a different president
isn't going to change the world in the
sense that we can't get access to them
he doesn't have to hear us out I I would
think that's it that's a terrific
terrific point and I think it's a
bipartisan point actually so it could
have been on either line and and you
know I've tried part of the front of the
problem in with Congress in
understanding Congress for many
Americans is there so many people in the
institution you have hundreds of people
there are scattered elections with with
the house every two years and senators
scattered and every every six years and
there's no single leader as you have
with the with the president even in the
house you have delay but you also have
Tom you've Hastert Denny Hastert who is
the speaker of the house you have the
whips you have the Democratic leadership
so it's a really messy institution with
scattered elections with many leaders
and I think it's hard it's a real
challenge for those of us who teach
about Congress for reporters who write
about Congress to kind of put it in some
order to make some sense of the
institution and I think that's one of
the challenges I've tried to do that
that's part of what i try to do with my
books and in my classes with
undergraduates but it's a big challenge
and I think for average citizens just
you know going about their business and
they only have a little time to watch
the news it's very difficult it's
something I think the media also has to
give more attention to in general the
media the mainstream news media does not
focus very much on Congress except for
when you have something like this delay
vote though the media loves the scandals
but they don't actually cover what
Congress is doing on a daily basis and
so it's a cycle that keeps replicating
itself and it makes it
very difficult for citizens to
understand what's at stake in the next
election cycle for Congress not for the
president a couple quick questions is
their tenure in the house and the Senate
when it comes to committee chair no
there is no tenure it's been handled in
different ways for much of the 20th
century was based on on seniority so it
was a kind of tenure in that it was a
practice it was a norm that the older
you got and the higher up the longer you
had served in the house you moved up the
committee ladder and eventually became
chairman so there was tenure in that it
was rare until the 70s to remove
chairman who were senior but it wasn't
any kind of right they could be removed
by their party at any given moment since
the 1970s parties have had a much
greater role in determining who the
chairman is and in reminding chairman
that if they buck the party
establishment there could be hell to pay
Democrats in 1974 and 75 removed for
chairman senior powerful chairman
including Wilbur Mills from their
position and and many legislators in the
70s and 80s would remember that that the
chair serves at the discretion of the
party recently in the Senate we saw Earl
inspector come out and make a very
strong statement about about you know
what what he wouldn't do on abortion in
any Supreme Court nominations and and
there was questions if Arlen Specter
would become the chair of the Judiciary
Committee again and i think the
compromise was the party has reminded
him that he has to be cautious in the
kind of statements he makes and
positions he takes so there's no tenure
and since the 70s the parties have
really been careful to put and make sure
that the chairs are loyal to the party
caucus and not independent at all
Jacksonville Alabama good morning Ryan
thank you for c-span because I love see
sense c-span because that's where you
can usually find out the truth but today
your guest he kind of brushed over and
painted the the thing with Tom DeLay
with a broad brush I want to know what
exact exactly happened with Tom DeLay
why is he being indicted because you
know I always heard you can indict a ham
sandwich and not only that but the
crat who brought up these charges was
found guilty of some of his own campaign
charges himself and also I heard that oh
I can't remember what the what the fella
did but basically he's out of the house
now himself so I was wondering if your
guests could please tell us what
campaign finances were being broken
thanks I think I think the two issues
that people have raised about tom delay
in in this recent case one is our events
that he held for interest groups such as
a golf event where I believe I don't
know all the details but that that money
was raised through through a golf event
with interest groups that that had
connections to legislation being
discussed that really skirted the
boundaries this is the accusation again
of what was legitimate the second is
that Tom DeLay used his power
excessively as Majority Leader in the
Texas redistricting case where there was
if you remember pressure put on
Democrats in Texas state legislature to
go along with the redistricting plan
that cost several Democrats their seats
including stint home one of the last
Southern moderates or southern
conservatives in in the house so those
were the two charges that have been
raised both these events which are
actually as the caller says quite common
but again it's if you're in the
leadership you're under a microscope on
these issues so you have to be very
clean and the second is this
redistricting which had enormous
consequences and and if you remembered
delay even allegedly helped gather up
Democrats who are trying to avoid a vote
in texas on the redistricting as a form
of protest that they were forcefully
brought back for a vote I want to just
10 seconds on the 10-year thing I
probably used the wrong word in the
house for instance the Dennis Hastert I
think said he would only serve three
terms is that a party rule or is he
going to serve only three terms and if
he doesn't do they Republican just going
to change the rules it's
party roll and that comes out of 1994
election when the Republicans and
Gingrich take over from the Democrats
they impose to term limits on committee
chairs i believe it was 46 years i might
be mistaken and on the speaker for eight
years and the idea was they were
building on her forms of the 70s that
there shouldn't be any kind of ten year
or permanency of position based on
seniority and this was a way to make
sure that you had fresh voices within
the party take over so it was a party
rule and I think there's already been
movement to reverse this and it's not
clear what Hastert that will do same in
the Senate with Bill Frist that the
Republican leadership is cut wrestling
with their own reforms at this point and
this term limit is it is in place you're
right but they can overturn it through
the party just as they did with the
delay issue it's it's it's open to
parties to change these things niceville
you're on the air yes good morning
professor Zelizer and bryant thank you
for having me a historical question I
want to ask you in context to what's
going on at least during 108 Congress
one that is going out now I've been
called by the senior one of the senior
Democratic senators offices is the most
prolific writer for the for them in the
United States Senate I've always tried
to bring the leadership and senator
Byrd's office together to try to ferret
out what's going on behind the scenes
and I think your book might be able to
enlighten me last year during the
Thanksgiving period of 2003 there was an
energy bill that came before Congress
and they were bengaline these
appropriations bills and they got held
up in the eleventh hour until the first
of the year and the reason being was
that on these appropriation bills the
clock had been working and they hadn't
got to him and they wanted to bendel
them all together and then pass him but
what happened when they came out of
conference there was a rule 26 in rule
15 of the United States Senate that
you're not allowed to legislate on
appropriation bills
and so when they come out of conference
you're either shut down the government
or you pass them but at the same time
there were new laws attached into
legislative laws rather than just the
purity of a spending and my question to
you is is that in your research because
you I noticed on your book which is to
me I'm going to get it is that it covers
a period up until two thousand was this
a rampant activity prior to the 107 and
108 Congress where they would do
legislation on Appropriations and that's
the question and I just want to make one
comment in context to that question
because you brought it up earlier is
that the reason like NBC News won't go
ahead and cover the machinations of
these uh behind-the-scenes rule-breaking
to get these spending bills across is
that they've always taken the position
that they just want to report on what
happens and not get into depth there but
the question is has this been a
historical thing in the Senate on the
Senate side I'm not as familiar with all
that the the rule changes in the outside
okay so got it thanks got the point yeah
it's been taking place since nineteen
seventy-four when Congress reforms the
budget process in both the House and the
Senate in the aftermath of or in the
middle really and aftermath of the
Watergate scandal and Richard Nixon's
impoundment of funds there is a general
dissatisfaction with the budget process
and one of the big arguments is it's too
decentralized you have appropriations
committees authorizing committees and
there's not even a congressional budget
and the argument was it had to be
centralized and some order had to be put
to the process so Congress creates these
budget committees in the House and
Senate and they create this elaborate
process whereby Congress makes a
congressional budget and not we don't
just follow a presidential budget and
and it's supposed to give a map to all
the committee's to follow and at the end
of the budget cycle everything is
brought together into a clean
congressional budget part of one of the
rules that is put in place is that
these budgets couldn't be filibustered
and in the Senate obviously one of the
big problems is always the filibuster
that senators and the majority have to
wrestle with and the aim was to protect
the overall budget from that filibuster
threat so since 1970 for what both
parties discovered is it's good to
bundle all kinds of bills in these big
budget bills because it protects them
from the floor in a way that other bills
aren't protected and the second part is
when they pass these big measures a lot
of legislators don't even see all the
details of what's in that budget
practice budget package so it's a good
way just literally sneak things in into
the bill since 74 Democrats have been
guilty of this as much as Republicans
this is a bipartisan use of the 74
budget reform that I think some people
now in both parties are a bit frustrated
with both because it limits the amount
of debate we have on the items in the
budget bills and because there's so much
in there it's almost impossible to know
often what you're passing that that also
came up recently so it's since the 70s
that's the phenomenon we've seen Glenn
may fee of states new service in today's
Washington Post has this fact since
january first 2003 ten thousand four
hundred and seventy two bills and
resolutions were introduced 6840 two in
the house 30 630 in the Senate by
November the first only 122 Senate bills
and 220 292 hospitals or four percent
had become law and this isn't even the
best of it the years back in the 60s
there were some 20,000 measures
introduced frazier park floor I'm
California I'm sorry go ahead please
yeah thank you very much for having me
on Brian I I wish to thank c-span for
this program and others that you
actually have during the year and i'm
going to miss booknotes tremendously in
any event i'd like to ask the professor
the following there seems to be some
turmoil in the Senate right now about
the advice and consent poor part of
nominating justices and getting various
judges appointed to the very
federal benches and there seems to be a
concerted effort on their part of
Republicans to say that it should be
5149 or at least 51 actual votes to
advise and consent that you that that
these nominees should should either be
pronounced appoint a bowl or or not in a
given session and I'd like to find out
what you think the Republicans can do in
terms of procedure to change that at
least specifically in this instance on
judicial nominees they essentially want
to change the filibuster rule that's
that's what they're talking about there
is interest now and this has been in the
papers again is one of the issues that
has made it into the papers and on the
media to eliminate the the filibuster
practice for judicial nomination so that
a simple majority can automatically vote
for judicial nominations and and and
that can be done the filibuster rule has
been changed in the past for in the
Senate there the rule of cloture which
is the rule that allows now 60 senators
to end debate was only created in 1917
in 1975 for example the Senate lowers
the number of senators needed to to
impose cloture to end debate on a
filibuster though so the filibuster is
not something that is set in stone it's
a tradition and the rules governing in
it have changed over time set a
Republican certainly can try to do that
it's it's a perfectly legitimate issue
I'm not sure they're going to have much
success you know if they change the
filibuster rule just for judicial
nominations a lot of people are
speculating it raises questions about
the filibuster in general why not get
rid of it all together and make the
Senate a majoritarian body just like the
house and there'll be a lot of
opposition both parties like the
filibuster Democrats and Republicans
like it it offers them a tool when
they're not in the majority and I think
oh that that's where the issue will will
emerge in terms of opposition to this
and and there are many who think it's
some kind of it's part of the Senate
that the the whole route the point of
the filibuster some think is to allow
any individual senator the power to
obstruct debate it's an anti
majoritarian measure that is good and it
reflects what the Senate is about so
there's going to be opposition on both
fronts I'm not sure it will change I
have on the desk here the American
Congress the building of democracy with
essays by Joanne Barry Freeman Jack in
rake-off ray Cove and why did that when
Alan Taylor and others but it's edited
by you Julian II selah's ER what is it
and I wanted to come out and what's in
it this book I just came out a few
months ago and it's it's a book that i
published with Houghton Mifflin and it's
a history of the Congress with 40 essays
from the start from the writing of the
Constitution to today to a chapter a
wonderful chapter on the conservative
movement and Congress since the 1980s
each chapter tries to capture a
different moment in the institution's
history going back to what I said
earlier when i started this book there i
couldn't find a single comprehensive
history of congress i was amazed that
someone could pick up and and gain a
sense of how how this institution has
changed over time so for example we have
an essay on congress in the New Deal
most people who study the New Deal know
about Franklin Roosevelt then and what
Roosevelt did in terms of creating
social security and creating the Wagner
at for organized labor this has a
chapter on Congress and the New Deal and
it focuses on people like Robert Wagner
a senator from New York who is the
originator and author of many of the
bills which we're familiar with from
that Great Depression era so so the book
also has a wonderful chapter on Congress
and civil rights in the 1940s and 50s
and looks at how committee chairman at
that time we're able to block passage of
civil rights legislation and how
northern Democrats and moderate
Republicans were able to overcome that
opposition so it has chapters and all
kinds of issues were familiar with
lavery reconstruction the progressive
yura the New Deal civil rights the 1960s
but it's from the perspective of
Congress and it tries to bring the
institution alive for readers not just
academic readers but just people who
want an initial introduction to this
institution right generally a delight to
work on rochester new york here on the
air go ahead please hello there brian i
have a theory developed a few years back
that that sea change happen in Congress
number years ago and jim wright was
removed and in terms of civility and so
on and I wonder if your guest has any
opinion on the hitter expand on that a
little bit why do you think that was so
important caller well just seemed to me
that that olives that all of a sudden
that got bloodier in Congress and then
it was they played that the heart the
hardball got much harder thanks Congress
has that the gym right incident takes
place between 1987 and 1989 that's when
speaker Jim Wright from Texas who is a
very strong party leader very strong
speaker in terms of using the rules of
the majority to advance what Democrats
want strong arming members of the
Republican Party just similar complaints
that we hear today is brought down and
Newt Gingrich who becomes the minority
whip in 1989 is key to that and they
they bring him down through revelations
of ethical wrongdoings again related to
campaign finance related to a book that
he published of his speeches that he
forced interest groups to buy if he
spoke to them and and and speaker right
is forced to resign I believe he's the
first speaker to resign because of
scandal charges in the middle in the
middle of his term and and for many both
Democrats and Republicans they say that
is a sea change it since then politics
became a little bit more vicious on both
parties and that there was more
willingness to use these ethics rules
against leaders against powerful leaders
and against the opposition party I'm not
sure that's where it starts I really
think the seventies is the key decade
again in 74 and 75 for senior chairman
in the Democratic Party are brought down
by Democrats and and other
the rest of the decade Wayne Hayes who's
an Ohio Democrat chairman of the House
Administration Committee has brought
down because of his relationship
personal relationship to his secretary
Elizabeth ray and and some would say
that's the decade where there was more
willingness to really go after leaders
and regardless of how much power they
had so I would just debt a dated a
decade back but yes we're in a hardball
year of politics in Congress Lynchburg
Virginia for Julian Zelizer go ahead
please thanks for taking my call Brian I
really appreciate c-span and all the
work that you're doing I just wanted to
thank the professor for his work on the
Congress thank you very much i really
appreciate it i was an undergraduate
history majors thinking about being a
history graduate student and i was
curious about the political bias that we
often see in history academically as a
professor i guess at Harvard and and
also at Boston University and spending a
lot of time in the Washington area what
do you think are some departments that
maybe you're leaning a little bit more
to the moderate side or for those of us
who might be looking looking to academia
but not not along the lines of the
traditional bias Thanks come to Boston
University and I think we're open to
everything I think the caller raises two
important points about academia the
first is there's actually been a bias
against studying politics in general
political institutions like Congress or
the presidency since the 1960's
historians have been much more
interested in social and cultural
history and it's only in about the last
six or seven years that you've had a
real renewed interest with graduate
students with professors and studying
the history of institutions such as
Congress and public policies like Social
Security so that part I think is good
for someone interested in these issues
as this renewal of interest in political
history the second part is there's
clearly a liberal bias in the Academy I
think most of the senior professors
right now are out of the 60s generation
and and again just like we were talking
about with Congress they are animated
they're motivated they're influenced by
those debates around Vietnam
around civil rights and I think there's
a bias against conservatives I do think
I do think that exists but that's not
the case everywhere again I'm not
plugging boston university but i've
worked in the past with students who are
on different sides of the political
spectrum and i know many other advisers
who do the same if you find I think a
good a good scholar I do think they're
ultimately open to studying and to
working with and to teaching students
about both sides of the political
equation and I finally I would say that
part of the think conservatives have
been very good in the media for example
it getting their positions known I mean
I think they really worked hard since
the 70s to establish different venues so
conservative ideas are very familiar to
most Americans I think they will have to
work in the Academy to do do the same
thing and I think a good generation of
scholars is very likely to emerge who
studies a little more from the right
than the left in your book you have a
picture from the Dirksen congressional
center and just so much in this picture
it's from May twenty-fifth of 1965 you
have Everett Dirksen Philip Hart Mike
Mansfield jacob javits and it's not he's
not identified but I think that's Tom
Kegel of California but the interesting
thing is you have a tube you have
buildings right now named after Philip
Hart and Everett Dirksen you have a room
named after Mike Mansfield and but the
only person alive in this picture today
is ted kennedy he was standing at the
back why so many people from the 60s
that have names in all these rooms and
buildings over in the capital now look
that was the when a lot of these
buildings were being named these these
were the giants of the period that if
you know the Philip Philip Hart the
Russell Richard Russell those those were
those were the Giants and and now those
who were that's where the name came from
you know Ted Kennedy at that period was
just a maverick he was just a young guy
trying to shake up the system and now
he's a senior leader in a time that the
buildings are named so that's not a good
time to make a name for yourself so i
think the buildings you can go through
Washington look at those buildings and
they reflect who who is the power in
Congress
during the 1940s and 60s it's a great
marker of the leaders of that generation
you have a picture i don't think i've
ever seen as before of a very young
Howard Smith it was the head of the
Rules Committee in the house from
Virginia first elected in 1930 we go to
st. Paul Minnesota go ahead you're on
the air st. Paul Minnesota you're on the
air yes can you hear me yes again okay
thank you I have a general question
regarding the issue of corruption in my
more cynical moments particularly after
elections I tend to think that the
Congress of the United States has become
at least borderline corrupt and when it
considered the sort of constant
fundraising and the need to raise money
you look at the gerrymandered districts
that enthroned people in their in their
districts seemingly for life and you
look at the things like the pork barrel
that was in the most recent budget bill
it's hard to it's hard to think of them
as acting out in the public interest
when the influence of money is obviously
so great so my question is maybe you
could disabuse me of my cynicism and is
there any sense in which you think of
the Congress as a corrupt institution
before we leave you sir you say
borderline corrupt what would it take
for you to call them just corrupt well
uh it's a good question and I suppose I
say a tongue-in-cheek but I think that
it's it's clear my sense is that most
most people in Congress probably would
like to do the right thing but that
frequently the it just gets blurred and
they oftentimes don't act in the public
interest thanks again pork barrelling
the gerrymandered districts and the
fundraising all of that you you call
them borderline correct I don't call
them borderline corrupt i call them big
problems that the institution has to
deal with but they you know the
gerrymandering system is not illegal
it's it's a system that we've had for a
long time and it's a system that's been
very talked about in the last 10 20
years the fact that you know state the
state governments draw lines to protect
incumbents and and and so that's not
kind of case of corruption it's a
political system some might see is
problematic but ultimately the voters
have a chance to act on it you know
voters can can put heat on state
government and on their representatives
and Senators to do something about that
to make seats more competitive but they
don't that's different than corruption
also the campaign finance system is
problematic look private money has a lot
of influence and clearly there's a lot
of legislators who feel a lot of
pressure from those who can give big
donations to them to both
representatives and Senators to at least
listen closely to what those interest
groups want but I don't think that's all
that guides legislators I mean I think
the more members I've met the more
members I've studied their first of all
there's many interest groups they face
that often reflect different parts of
the constituency environmental movement
for example has a lot of power on
Capitol Hill just just as a just as
business doesn't for a while organized
labor had power so there's a lot of
people giving money it's not clear that
one person is buying Congress and voters
also have power you know ultimately
legislators or political animals and
they pay close attention to what's going
to put them in office in the next
congressional election and and so I
don't think those that doesn't matter
either so there's big problems that
Congress faces but I don't think it's
corrupt and I think most of what
Congress does is work hard on difficult
compromises that that that you know try
to deal with the incredible differences
on the in this country on hard issues so
I wouldn't use the word corruption we
had a fax from a Gavin halder had alder
I'm not sure that's where he pronounced
it from Portland Oregon I think you
answered most of his questions I want to
make sure you knew we got it may feel
Kentucky you're on the air good morning
Brian I love your show man i'm going to
miss book notes thank you i have bought
a lot of books because of this show
because of book notes but I'm a
schoolteacher all the time I get to see
you guys live is during holiday periods
like this my question for the professor
and by the way I just love what you're
saying here my question is this in most
high schools I don't know he probably
wear this in most high schools
government is not a required subject in
most junior high school civic
is not a required subject and the few
times I've been able to teach it I
thought it as an elective you know
Advanced Placement government because
they wanted to you know have another AP
course or something like that and I
think it's an absolute shame that
something this important is not a
required subject what are your comments
on that I i have several comments the
first actually goes back to the last
question and ties them two together you
know there are all these problems that
we know about they're not secrets in
politics the campaign finance issues and
and part of what has to happen
ultimately as voters have to put
pressure on their politicians they have
to take a vested interest in what
government is doing and what Congress is
doing and they have to vote and they
have to vote in favor of the reforms
that people are calling for one of the
big problems with reformed is it doesn't
really attract voters usually it sounds
good but it's not an issue we're voting
on so I think the more people learn
about Congress the more people follow a
Congress is doing the more seriously we
can think about fixing this democratic
system in in ways that are positive the
second is is is it's it's very important
that we revitalize civic interest
through what students are taught those
early years are absolutely crucial to
young women and men in developing their
attachment to the political system one
of the big issues in American politics
today is not whether you're democrat or
republican it's not whether you're for
Social Security or against it it's
whether you vote or you don't vote and
it's whether you're really engaged in
the political system and it's in our
educational system that we actually have
a chance to do a lot about that and if
there has been a big decline which
there's evidence in how civics is taught
and how much we learn about government
at a young age that's something we
really need to deal with and that's when
we can start seriously acting on this
problem of political disengagement Las
Vegas Nevada for Julian Zelizer go ahead
please hi Brian and hi professor sellers
here I had two more questions on the
filibuster the first one is when did
they change the rule so that you did not
actually have to speak on the floor to
maintain the filibuster
and didn't the Republicans make
extensive use of that change in the rule
in the early 90s when the Democrats
controlled the Senate Thanks yeah
there's to try to two issues one in 1975
they create this to track system whereby
if there's a filibuster you can also
handle handle other business and and
this takes place as the practice of
actually getting up and speak like like
mr. Smith goes to Washington the famous
scene where we actually speak in a
filibuster during the 70's and 80's that
practice it's a practice not a rule
diminishes and basically you just
threaten the filibuster and that's what
the parties have done and you don't
actually go through through the motions
of doing it so it's been a it's actually
that the lack of speaking is just its
enormous a tradition that's gone except
in a few few occasions and the second
part of the question like am sorry I was
did them the Republicans make use of
this think it's i knew i didn't i don't
i'm sorry i don't remember but i def if
that's the question if that's the
question yes I mean Republicans have
used the threat and actual filibuster
many times since the 1970s it's a
bipartisan affair the use of filibusters
increased dramatically since 1975 and
before that there weren't as many
filibusters and they were usually the
filibuster was reserved for big issues
like civil rights since the 1970s both
parties have used filibusters as a kind
of normal party tool to attack all kinds
of issues from minor bills to the budget
and and and so I think getting back to
an earlier discussion that's part of the
reason Republicans I think many are
going to have questions about really
threatening this truck this tradition
they've used it as well they realize
it's a pretty good tool this is the book
it's called on Capitol Hill the struggle
to reform Congress than its consequences
48 to 2000 and I want to apologize we
got a couple calls to go but I have
lapsed as I'm sure you had happened to
you before into calling you selas are
instead of Zelizer and I apologize how
often find out I want to know that
happens a lot so I'll feel a little
better I I have had
I name all kinds of incarnations of my
name Ziegler's that was our it's a
family tradition so that you've done a
great job on that actually pembroke
pines florida you're on the air thank
you very much good morning morning I'm
curious to know how the professor feels
about the negative method in which the
program West Wing deals with Congress I
find it a little difficult to comprehend
since I worked on the hill for quite a
few years how'd you work for I work for
Senator Javits Thank You of New York
it's actually I mean it's I don't watch
The West Wing I've seen a couple
episodes and I've actually seen the
depiction of legislators the West Wing
is certainly not the only kind of Mecca
culture show or movie that uses this
depiction depictions and car of Congress
in film and television are almost always
very negative West Wing is one example
there was a film Bulworth that came out
a few years ago with Warren Beatty in
which Warren Beatty plays a senator who
came of age in the 60s and once was
idealistic about civil rights about war
and had been completely corrupted by the
institution to the point you know he's
essentially assassinated when he
questions the the kind of system he
works for you'll find that all over and
I think it's a problem because I think
again since we're not learning about
this stuff in high schools and since the
media tends to focus the mainstream
media on scandal and and the most
dramatic moments of an institution like
the delay vote if all people see are
these negative depictions I fear that it
will just continue to aggravate the
distrust we have of government which has
a healthy component but if that's all
you see that's really unfortunate one
more call for our guests we go to
Minneapolis Minnesota good morning good
morning I'll try to be very brief the
term rules to me means something that
you follow that are fixed and unchanging
like Robert's Rules of Order but when I
watch c-span the rules for instance of
the house seemed to change on a daily
basis and that to me is
ruption the notion of constantly
changing readjusting rules in order to
get something you want to get done to me
it's just unbelievable i don't
understand that can you explain it i'd
say i mean the first part is the rules
don't change every day i think that
would be a slight exaggeration often
what you see or politicians using rules
in place they're using more aggressively
sometimes than others most of the things
Republicans are doing are legitimate
rules legitimate uses of party power
that that that that aren't you know that
it isn't illegal at all the second thing
remember is this is a democratic
institution so when you have rules for a
democratic institution it is important
that they could change look if the
country changes in certain rules become
problematic or become distasteful that
there's an argument to be made that
since this is a democracy we want to
have rules that can that can fluctuate
within the seventies when they reform
the committee system and and try to
limit the power of seniority and try to
strengthen the parties and say that
these senior chairman can't do whatever
they want that is a change in rules it's
a change in practice but for many people
it was a way to improve democracy was a
way to bring new leadership that was
more in touch with the country whether
on the right in the left then those old
Southern conservative Democrats so I
think that's the answer that's the
reason we have it but we do have to be
careful that the the changes in the
rules don't become excessive and that
they're not used in ways that at least a
majority doesn't doesn't want professor
Zelizer where his hometown originally
I'm from a touch in New Jersey I grew up
there where my mother is a professor my
father's a rabbi and I lived there until
college when I went to Brandeis here in
Boston and graduate school in johns
hopkins and and lived in albany and now
i'm back in boston so I'm a New Jersey
Central thanks a lot for joining us this
morning thanks for having me our guest
was in Boston again here is his book on
Capitol Hill it's published by Cambridge
and the other book that he edited is
called the American Congress the
building of a democracy the history of
Congress our guest has been Julian
zella zert from Boston professor at BU
and we thank him for joining us there's
a lot of activity on the network over
the weekend you might be interested in
on Saturdays callin program on the
Western journal David bond Aviation Week
senior editor and Arthur Auerbach of
Goodman & Company Washington DC for one
hour from nine until ten he's a senior
manager and as we often do topic his
year-end tax advice on sunday ave or avi
jewish who is the author of beacon of
hatred guest book is on his bala back TV
al manner and its impact on the arab
population also michael kirgan Canadian
ambassador to the United States and
Wolfgang pissinger will join us for the
last 45 minutes from 915 on plenty on
book TV and on Sunday night for book
notes second to last book notes we have
this the author of the biography of
Franklin Pierce who just finished his
200th anniversary thanks for joining us
have a good weekend